it was weird in my head in my head I
kind of already assumed well we've got
this
in my head at that age I'd suddenly gone
like yeah we've got this and then I
remember it wasn't long enough that a
Truman Show movie had come out and I had
this weird like maybe this is just like
a whole thing
you know and it was like everything's
rolling too perfectly
um and then yeah I just I just always
assumed that we were going to be Fred
and George
in the films there's bizarre confidence
that I've never had before James did you
feel that
I found it I mean I had nothing to
compare it with it was it's always where
it felt like it felt like you can
imagine I mean like I guess it just came
a natural thing where you imagine
yourself in the role
when you're doing the audition because
that's good for the audition but
um yeah we'd like you saying with every
other audition because I was like five
or six of them in total it gets more
real than you get and you know that you
must be doing something or actually
further down the line and I've never
been more nervous in all my life than
when we were in that
um screen test
because the use is touching distance at
that point I mean you've been there many
times so you you know you know that it's
it's reachable
that's what scares you when you're
thinking about it like you know oh my
God this is real this is real how do I
stay I mean and you're 14 how you don't
know how to keep it together you don't
know how to act cool you don't and I
think that's probably the charm that
maybe you guys had
you know I think so I mean the one the
one thing I did remember from the screen
test is because yeah it's a Weasley
Ginger that we ended up having
when filming and they try they were
trying a a temporary hair dye and I
remember they put it on I thought this
looks
just like you know I've got slightly
light and brown hair but this isn't
going to work maybe we don't look as
they thought and then
so but you kind of like push that to the
back of your head I suppose when doing
it but it was just I remember when they
when we got the uh got the roll I can't
even remember if they must have
mentioned it but I can't even remember
them mentioning that they were gonna dye
ahead
I just remember just it was like an
unsaid thing
wow well I remember them saying I
remember uh I think it's Chris Columbus
saying to us and you guys are okay with
your hair being dyed right last night
you can shave my head for like yeah you
know you know that's like that yeah
my God I mean did you read the books or
obviously you read the books after for
sure or the book I know how many books
were out there I'm not a big reader but
uh you know did you ever were you like
wait a minute
we're in the books you guys are there
throughout the books right
so the yeah the so the first audition
happened and the fourth book had just
come out and it was the first like
publicized midline midnight launch of a
book in however long because obviously
the books were they got I always say
they got a new generation reading around
the world which is so that's why the the
film was going to be a big thing
um and we'd read the first book so we
knew the characters
from the first book but then I started
reading the second and the third book
over that summer
and
the third book so they're in the prison
of Azkaban which I think is my favorite
book out of the sea out of the series
and you know the smell that a book has
right
um that smell no matter what book I'm
reading now reminds me of reading the
Prisoner of Azkaban in the summer of
2000 when we were casting the roles
uh it's just just little things like
that yeah wow